thank you
hey everybody happy Sunday happy Sunday
look I kind of like rearrange some of
the stuff in the backy but probably
can't see it but remember all the stuff
that I showed you guys that Sophie had
sent me yeah uh yeah like I got so what
I don't have like I gotta get it um you
have power to it yeah no you got to get
an extension cord yeah I gotta get an
extension cord because we have some
extension cords but they're all being
used right now so everybody little
Dracula light up thing I want to light
up back there yeah it's different now
some of the stuff back there is kind of
like the yellow posters that I was she
didn't give me those I had those from
like a long time ago I just got around
to framing them it does look better
yeah you know looks a little more
orderly everything looks straighter than
it did
well I didn't change like most of the
stuff it was just like little stuff here
and there but so maybe you might just be
imagine it maybe
um but yeah so you guys several of you
had like uh talked about wanting us to
do chud so I was like last and I was
like yeah what the hell yeah I actually
hadn't seen this
I saw it a bunch of times like on cable
I don't think I've ever seen when I was
a kid like in the 80s yeah and I
remembered kind of like like me and my
brother used to kind of like watch it
all the time and there's a sequel to it
too which is called chud too bud the
chud
um which and I kind of remember that one
although I also remember that one has
absolutely nothing to do with the first
one and it's almost kind of like it was
like a zombie comedy that they just
slapped the name on because it doesn't
have anything to do with the first one
but um this one it's weird because I
remembered this one being more funny
than it was and it's actually not funny
it's actually like I mean it has funny
parts but it actually is kind of like
taken more seriously you know what I'm
saying yeah I've never seen this one I
had a hard time getting into it it
didn't hold my attention for some reason
I didn't have I I don't know I guess
they didn't have a Nostalgia for it or
something but uh I don't know I just I
just I didn't like it
it kind of reminds me of the only
criticism that I can give to it because
I actually like this movie's like
actually like much better than I
remember but if there is one criticism
I'd say it needs it needed more Monster
stuff
um yeah yeah although that I don't know
that didn't bother me as much because
the acting in this is like way better
than it has any right to be it's got a
lot of good actors in it that's what I'm
saying once you remember you know yeah
like your first movie you know what I
mean there's there's a lot of famous
actors in it yeah John heard was in this
um uh Daniel Stern was in this both of
them were uh got real famous in home
alone obviously uh John Goodman was in
it like for a second he was like played
a cop in a diner like in one scene but
like there's a bunch of like really
famous character actors and stuff like
that in this so I think like the the
acting and this is like really A Cut
Above but it's almost it's almost kind
of plays out like a um almost like a
police procedural for like maybe the
first half or like three quarters of it
and you kind of see the monsters like
sometimes but I don't know I kind of
really got into that though but I can
see how some people that are just
because the title of it is chud and I
feel like people wanted more of like a
schlocky monster movie I was expecting
more like humanoids from the deep right
it does have a schlocky monster movie
aspect to it but it's kind of like takes
itself a lot more seriously and it like
I said it's kind of more about like the
drama and then like the move the
monsters don't really show up like until
the end but I mean the gore in this is
really really good like I remember
um you know because I thought the
monsters do kind of look cheesy by
today's standards but the monsters
actually look a lot better than I
remember and also all the gore like
people there's like you know like
severed heads and like severed arms and
[ __ ] like that like laying all over the
[ __ ] uh sewer I thought that looked
like really really good you know I mean
considering that this movie probably
know what it was it's I mean it costs
probably only like a million dollars to
make Maybe
it didn't pull me in in the first
[ __ ] 10 minutes and usually if a
movie does not pull me in within the
first 10 minutes it never really does
um and then I end up not really getting
into it
um I was getting bored during this one
uh I kept checking my [ __ ] thing and
this is look I gotta I got a [ __ ]
start heating up food you know and I'm
walking away from the movie
but that's just typical with me I I know
if I'm not [ __ ] captured in in first
15 minutes I'm not gonna like it
probably and it's just
this is one of those I didn't really
like it now maybe if I approached it
different time under a different mindset
and maybe
had I seen it a long time ago
you know
and maybe had good memories of it maybe
I would have watched it better but I
watched it more closely but I just I
just couldn't get into it it kind of
reminded me like watching it again it
kind of reminds me of like a Larry Cohen
movie because it's just it's not but it
kind of like reminded me of that Vibe
because it was shot in New York but did
he do cute yeah yeah yeah that's what I
was thinking it reminded me of cue the
week yeah it was kind of like that like
I said it's shot in New York like during
the time when New York was still really
like scuzzy and trashy and everything
like that it kind of gave me a little
bit it's kind of like Street trash too
but I mean Street trash is like way more
over the top
um you know with the bums dissolving
into like all this like colored goo or
whatever so it's like a lot weirder than
this one I kind of feel like this one is
kind of more like a Larry Cohen movie
except like mixed with Toxic Avenger
because in the 80s you had that had this
kind of like
um which I guess was kind of like a
throwback to the 50s where you had all
these monster movies is where the
monsters were caused by like radiation
or nuclear waste and you know toxic
waste and stuff so I feel like that's
kind of what this was as well but like I
said it's almost kind of like I can't
decide if it should have been schlockier
I think it should have been and more
monsters
I do think there's they should have had
the monsters in there more yeah like I
think they held out a little bit too
long but I'm not like giving it I'm not
[ __ ] on it too much because I really
did like all the actors like I said
there's great actors in this and I kind
of got like all involved in the even
though you know this came out in 1984
and it's like I know they're chuds you
know what I mean because I've seen the
movie before so it's like there's no
mystery to the thing it's like where are
all these homeless people disappearing
I'm like the chuds the chuds are eating
them you know what I mean although wait
I didn't get the okay
it's been a while since I've seen this
where I washed it again last night it's
on 2B by the way for free as is Bud to
as uh Bud the chud the chud too that's
also onto on 2B for free
now I think in the original version of
The Script
I think the chuds were supposed to be
like the homeless people that were down
like the undergrounders as they called
them like the ones that lived down in
like the sewers and the old subway
tunnels and stuff like that the toxic
waste that they've been storing down
there unbeknownst to anyone was turning
the was turning the homeless people into
the chuds like cannibalistic human
humanoid underground dollars you know
what I mean
um so I guess that's what it was because
I think wasn't there one scene like
where they went down like the one guy
got bit by one and like a real nasty
wound and like Vic was his name and then
like way later on in the movie like they
find him again and I think they find
that same guy again and he's kind of
like mid chud like like he's turning
into it he's kind of like proto-chod and
it's just kind of like and then he has
to like shoot him because he's like
turning into a chud
so I'm guessing that's what it is
because that's what the original script
was supposed to be like and I think they
backed off on that little bit but I
think that idea is still in there
they're in there talking about Street
trash was only good only the first
[ __ ] half hour was good when it was
crazy that was the ones with the bumps
turning into the dam yeah like melting
into gear and then they forgot about
that and the movie became something else
then it kind of wandered I wandered off
and it never really came back so it
really you know
the street trash was the good the first
like month quarter of it was good yeah I
like the idea of it but then like I
forgot about what the movie was yeah I
was like yeah this is awesome like
melting bombs and everything like that
but then they kind of It kind of like
wandered up and started doing something
else and I'm like what happened in the
mouth
yeah I like that so
this one I mean I think it's a good
attempt I would have gone schlockier
with it I would have gone more humanoids
from the deep
or what was the one with the damn cicada
like extra was it called extra no what
was the name what was the one Beast
Within
Beast Within oh the one we did where the
guy cicada yeah yeah I think he stopped
the Beast with it did we talk about that
like that yeah not too long ago it was
good what a weird [ __ ] movie that was
at least within is yeah
Southern horror movie [ __ ] cicadas
coming up you turned it into a damn
cicada yeah because cannibals I don't
know it never really explained it they
made the dude eat dead bodies and he
became a sagada which that has nothing
to do with cicadas but I mean yeah yeah
so you know you know how that happened
that's how the South rolls I mean at
least this one made sense you know what
I mean like so like the nuclear
Regulatory Commission or whoever were
like have secretly been putting toxic
waste down on the New York subways for
all of this time and it started like
leaking out and like all the homeless
people that were living down there
started turning into chuds and they
started coming out through the manholes
and like eating people it's like pretty
easy to understand I think it tried to
be a little too serious it tried to make
you take this premise seriously and
that's that's the problem it should have
just been now [ __ ] it and it had been
just monsters
you know
um they were trying to do kind of what
mimic did remember the movie mimic yeah
it was trying to be mimic mimic was
almost kind of serious
well maybe it came out later that's what
I'm saying yeah you know but they were
trying to do what mimic did
which is take a monster movie make it
kind of plausible
but the script wasn't right the special
effects weren't right mimic did that
though much later
um
but that's what I think it was it was
trying to be what mimic was they had
never seen mimic but that's what they
were shooting for I think that was based
on a novel but and I read the novel but
I don't remember what year the novel of
it came out perhaps after this I'd
imagine I remember when mimic came out I
saw the movie and I was blown away
because it was kind of like a realistic
monster movie
and um Turned out it wasn't a monster at
all it was just a big ass cockroach that
could fold itself up and look like a man
but it was an illusion you know which is
one of the worst things that I can think
of because man I hate cockroaches and if
there was like a cockroach that was big
enough to like kind of fold itself into
a person yeah and then like pretend that
it was a person and then be like
surprised of a cockroach nobody did eat
you right and there was there was more
than one of them I don't like that I
don't like that so and it was kind of in
in those days it felt plausible like
something like that could actually
happen and I think that's what the
problem with this was is they were
trying to make these chuds plausible
with the limited budget that they had I
thought that I think the chuds look cool
though I especially like their glowing
eyes yeah but they tried to make them
plausible by putting a bunch of acting
and a bunch of dialogue in there that's
not how you do it
well maybe they didn't have enough money
to like they're like well we can't but
like I said when they do show the chuds
I think they look cool and when they
show like all the gore like people that
got their heads pulled off and their
arms pulled off and stuff like that that
looks really good I think the special
effects look really good so I kind of
feel like if you're going to if you
don't have enough money and they're like
well we want to show like this much
monster and this much Gore and stuff
like that at least I mean it show it
less but make it look better because if
you try to like stretch it too thin and
show the monsters a whole bunch and the
gore a whole bunch but you got to cheap
out on it then I don't think it's gonna
be as good so I think they did what they
could with it you know what I'm saying
yeah I don't know I think the girl would
happen and the thing about it is that
well you yeah you missed a lot too like
because you kept it and honestly like
you missed a lot of the best [ __ ] like
you know what I mean like once it kind
of like really ramped up and started
because I will admit that it takes a
while to get where it's going but you
know because at the start it kind of
starts out like like I said you know and
I know and everyone knows that it's
chuds because you know it's it's we know
it's 84. but you know and we've seen the
monster at the beginning like coming out
from the um you know from the manhole
and like taking that lady in the dog or
whatever but you know you're just kind
of like watching the characters like fig
trying to figure out like what's going
on with it and then so you have
um Daniel Stern who's playing like the
guy that's like the Reverend who runs
the soup kitchen and he's the one that
notices all the homeless people missing
and then you got John heard playing like
a photographer who had done a series on
uh homeless people that lived down there
and so he kind of gets involved in it
and then you got like a cop who is kind
of like why the [ __ ] are all these
people going missing because it's not
just homeless people it's like other
people too and you know then like the
higher ups keep telling him hey why
don't you just like forget all about
those missing people because I have
reasons you know what I mean because
they're trying to like cover it all up
and everything so it what it is kind of
like they are trying to do kind of like
a bigger story I guess but they're
trying to talk about like uh you know
this regulatory group that's coming in
here and like
like having all this stuff down here
secretly and like they don't want
anybody to know about it so they're
trying to like maintain the cover-up but
they can't maintain the cover-up because
you know people are turning into chuds
and like coming out and like eating
people like eating one little girl's
Grandpa like right in front he reaches
right into the dam right right into the
damn phone booth and eats Grandpa right
in front of the little girl
I remember the police station near the
police station where'd they get those
old buildings there's a lot of those
that showed up in the movies in the 80s
well this was shot in New York city so
I'm assuming they shot it on location
somewhere it wasn't a police station it
was some kind of office building but
yeah probably just reminded me of the
way offices used to look and then I
think those were like something from the
40s or the 50s kind of repainted in 80s
colors and redecorated but it's funny to
see that that kind of architecture again
there's a lot of it in 80s B movies yeah
it's cheap to shoot there
locations like that yeah it was just you
know
this definitely does give me it I would
definitely put this in the kind of uh
similar kind of sub genre as the like
scuzzy New York films that came out like
in the 70s and 80s like Maniac or like
Larry Cohen's movies or like Basket Case
or movies like that there when when you
could shoot in New York and New York
look like a big [ __ ] like it's
returning to now evidently well you know
and you could shoot back there for cheap
like nowadays you can't like so usually
if you want to set something in New York
City nowadays they just do like the out
the exteriors in New York and then they
shoot the rest in like Toronto or
whatever but um because it's too
expensive but you know I don't know it
because it's just too I guess back in
the old days it was like lots of uh
neighborhoods where there wasn't too
much traffic so you could kind of do it
without
causing too much uh problem like with
the traffic and everything like that so
there was kind of like a whole sub-genre
of those I feel like this too this also
kind of gives me the same Vibe which is
another movie that I've been wanting to
do on the show is uh alligator from
1980. I don't remember that one that was
the one about because you know the urban
legend about how everybody oh they got
little baby alligators for uh for you
know at the pet store and then they got
too big and they got flushed down the
toilet and then like there was
supposedly some story Back in the New
York Times a long time ago that it's
like some kids like pulled an eight-foot
alligator out of the [ __ ] [ __ ] I
don't believe it which I don't think
that's true I think I've never survive a
New York winner I know I don't think
they would either and they have to bask
in the Sun a lot they stay we live in
alligator territory they got to be up on
a land basket trying out well they're
cold-blooded they don't yeah you gotta
heat up and uh no they would never
survive in a sewer it's not a sunlight
there's not enough fish they got they
have a [ __ ] big dietary requirements
but it's still a fun movie though yeah
at least that I remember because
alligator I mean to me like alligators
are scary so I remember being I mean I'm
sure I saw alligator that came out in
1980 so I probably saw it when I was 9
or 10 years old and I remember that
scaring the crap out of me yeah eight
foot alligator could never survive in
New York it could never grow to that
length I can understand a [ __ ] 16
inch 18 inch alligator but it died the
first winter
Pat Hatfield said alligator is great I
remember alligator being a really good
movie like I said that was another one
that maybe we'll do it on um maybe we'll
do it on Tuesday because I've been
wanting to re-watch that uh Danny
Rowling said don't John hurt's character
and uh AJ AKA Daniel Stern's character
get infected by the radiation and
Cooper's girlfriend or baby get infected
by the chud bite see I'm not sure about
that because
you would think that the two guys I mean
they were down in the sewers and they
were like trapped down there for a while
because they couldn't get out you know
because they were gonna blow they were
trying to blow up all the chuds so they
like filled all the subway like all the
tunnels with gas and they got stuck down
there and they wandered into like the
main kind of uh area where all the chuds
were mutating I guess and there was like
very clearly like toxic green toxic
waste like splattered all over
everything and they're just like oh no
toxic waste I'm like yeah you might want
to get away with that away from that
because you know it's turning people
into chuds so I don't know now well the
thing about it though is that is that
John heard's character he knocked up his
girlfriend before any of these
Shenanigans happened I would assume
right because she found out she was
pregnant
before they went down there so I don't
see why the baby would be infected she
went down into the tunnels for like a
little bit but I don't think she was in
the part that where the where the toxic
waste was so she'll probably be all
right
but I don't she didn't get bit by a
child did she who I don't remember her I
didn't get I didn't see her get bit by a
Judd
I didn't like him all that [ __ ] was
going on I was coming back up and I was
just like uh yeah I just couldn't get
into the movie early on so and a lot of
people are agreeing with me that it it's
it takes a long time for it to get
started and a lot of it's nostalgia but
I never
you know I I never saw this movie so I
didn't I just didn't form a connection
with it
the weird thing about it is that
you know when it came out it obviously
was kind of like a little bit of a flop
when it came out but over the years it
kind of developed this really big cult
following and then it kind of got
referred to like on a bunch of different
shows like The Simpsons and all this
other kind of stuff so much so that
chuds became like a a word like it was
added to the American lexicon which is
crazy and I think maybe
because you would think that because of
that because of the reputation that it
has that this movie be like wackier than
it is and it's not wacky yeah not really
it's definitely better than trancers
it's better than a lot of movies that
came out in the 80s I'm going to say and
like I said I was kind of like thinking
about this before and I was just kind of
like I can see how maybe
um you know yeah it should have showed
the monsters more and stuff and maybe it
should have been like more fun and
schlocky but then I was like I don't
know though because there were a lot of
movies like that in the 80s and I kind
of liked all the acting in this one and
I kind of liked like the police
procedural and the more the mystery
aspect of it I thought that was kind of
cool and I kind of liked that they were
taking it serious they were doing
something a little bit different you
know what I mean it wasn't like real
goofy like Toxic Avenger was kind of
goofy you know and I just or Street
trash was kind of goofy and it wasn't
really you know what I mean it had like
goofy Parts in it but it wasn't really
meant to be goofy it didn't seem like
yeah they always talk about what is
better than it's better than [ __ ]
killer tomatoes yeah it is yeah Killer
Tomatoes is fun but I think
last time I watched kill the Attack of
the Killer Tomatoes I kind of feel like
that's a funny idea but actually like
sitting through it is something else
entirely you know what I'm saying if
you've never seen trancers don't see it
if you've seen your answers and liked it
as a kid don't see it okay don't don't
watch transfers that's a piece of [ __ ]
because I had a good memories of it I
went and watched it and then we watched
it again and I was like yeah what
happened to you I was like did you fall
on your head as a child I'm like this is
a terrible movie
we liked it when we were kids it had
some good ideas guys doing time travel
through their ancestral DNA that's a
great idea it's a real good idea and we
I think we mostly remembered that idea
yeah an opening and the opening
um kind of Blade Runner type scene
that's happening in the future and they
got those [ __ ] up cars look like
they're from the 50s they're in the
diner and they have the [ __ ] shootout
that's the best part of the movie the
rest of it's [ __ ] garbage boring
really I liked the opening scene but
then after that I was just kind of like
and for some reason I think just those
that that opening scene and some of the
ideas stuck with us but maybe we didn't
like the movie maybe we just liked the
idea of [ __ ] time travel through your
ancestral lines and then you just
created your own movie in your head
based around that idea and then later on
you thought that that's what the real
movie was that's what we thought
I might just I think I've had that
happen to me we might have been just
just talking about that idea and for
some reason we like that movie Just
because that idea but we didn't actually
like the movie
you know teenage boys have a way of
rationalizing [ __ ]
you know yeah it was just a piece of
[ __ ] movie
but we so we thought that [ __ ] was
underground as cool as [ __ ] because yeah
that should yeah they weren't
compromising on that movie you know I
mean that's what we how we would think
yeah that was Hardcore yeah that's not
commercial there you know that kind of
[ __ ] no it just sucked
yeah [ __ ] it
Danny Rowling said it's funny that
someone shut the sky on Val's character
and he died that way yeah I liked that
too I was like that was pretty shitty
away Valen I liked that character he
played a good uh Maniac yeah oh and
Danny rolling said yeah when she cuts
its head off it bit her ankle before
dying oh that's right I totally forgot
about that I must have been like looking
away or getting a drink or something
like that why so that was another thing
too like when she was going to cut its
head off why did it like extend its neck
like that yeah see caravanson says he
remembered transfers being good as a kid
too don't see it man you're gonna be
disappointed well I don't know
everybody's away I remember different I
had never seen it as a kid it was so you
kept like talking it up and I was like
okay well I paid a lot of money man I
paid 40 bucks to get chancers [ __ ] on
on Blu-ray yeah and you were like you
kept talking it up and down
man I was like this isn't that good it's
got a lot of time it's got a lot of
pointless dialogue in it a bunch of
filler
and not a whole lot happens well that's
the thing I kind of feel like a lot of
movies from the 80s even movies that
people remember fondly if it was like
really really cheap I mean special
effects and all that kind of stuff that
should cost money yeah so to get a movie
to like 85 90 minutes you're gonna have
to put in a lot of talking and a lot of
like you gotta feel Roger Corman knew
that that's why [ __ ] walked
around for 30 minutes in his [ __ ]
film just walking around and walking
around walking around and evidently they
made [ __ ] eight of those transfers
movies like six or eight of them that's
crazy they were all directed DVD it has
its own fan base but they made a lot of
them
I wouldn't recommend them though yeah
Pat says my taste must suck because I
love chud and I love trancers both
favorite 80s B movies well like I said
everybody's taste is different I
actually I really like chud as well I
remember not being crazy about the
sequel because it didn't have anything
to do with the first one but I actually
thought chud was like a pretty good
[ __ ] movie and I was like because I
even told him he's he came in like after
and he was I was just like man that was
actually better than I remembered
because I was remembering it I guess
because the title is so goofy like
people are expecting it to be like
schlock here and I remembered it being
schlockier and it's not I think I would
have liked it better if it was just
maybe but please are [ __ ] you know
something but yeah kativasan just
brought up Ghoulies I kind of I I don't
know the only the only thing I remember
about Ghoulies which I think is probably
the only thing anybody who remembers
about Ghoulies is the you know the VHS
cover with like the little monster
coming out of the toilet
um I don't even remember if I saw that
movie I'm sure I did
it's but the thing about Ghoulies is
that I'm guarantee that it must be
better than hobgoblins
I don't remember that one
um if you want to see hobgoblins which I
don't recommend but see the version
that's on Mystery Science Theater
because that is hilarious like they
eviscerated that [ __ ] it's honestly I'm
a big fan of like well all of the movies
that they do on MST it's like it's
always funny
but to me like the funniest ones are the
ones from the 70s and 80s
um and because that was like one of the
80sest movies that ever 80s
um then it that was like super super
funny like and the 80s fashions in it
were just horrific and it was just like
it was just like these little monsters
like these clearly these little puppets
and like they come to Earth in this tiny
tiny little spaceship it's like this big
and it's just like oh my God it's so
awesome ah but yeah Ghoulies is another
one we should do but I definitely want
to do alligator because this watching
this reminded me of alligator because
that was kind of the same thing I mean
they're not sure it's an alligator to be
kind of like prophecy
is it probably gonna be about like
prophecy I I remember it being better
than prophecy but because because we
just did prophecy not too long ago right
because we just watched it there yeah
with the with the Bears yeah I thought
that looks pretty cool doesn't look
pretty cool yeah and the alien came out
I think a year later and blew it away it
was that was the end of Prophecy well
yeah I mean that's the thing like alien
comes out in 1979 and it was just like
mic drop walking away from the explosion
in slow motion and all that kind of
stuff and everybody's just like seeing
you went away well it was like Logan's
Run was badass and then [ __ ] year
later Star Wars came out and that was it
for Logan's Run
bye bye Logan's Run
yeah
yeah
Star Wars [ __ ] kicked its ass
kind of oddsan said I don't remember if
you guys have done the Hellraiser Saga
we did the first one we did the first
one but I don't I don't think I've done
any of the sequels I remember the second
one being okay and I think I saw the
third one and I didn't really like it
and I don't think I bothered with any of
these I Remember Loving Hellraiser until
I went back and looked at him I watched
them more recently and they're boring uh
and then I remembered that really what I
liked was
as a kid was the scenes with the Cena
bites in them well yeah and anything
outside that they just it was just kind
of
filler really it wasn't that wasn't that
good
just you know they weren't that good
and they were um
they were movies of their time yeah you
know
they're kind of boring by today's
standards I don't find it boring but you
know that's kind of that's your thing I
guess yeah for me they're boring Danny
Rowling said I just saw the 1995 film
copycat I've been wanting to do that
again too because I saw that movie in
the theater and I remember really really
liking it and I think I saw it one other
time like after that on uh cable but I
remember liking that a lot I think I put
it in the poll a couple times too
because it was on one of our streaming
services but it didn't win so we didn't
do it yeah Sigourney Weaver is in it uh
but yeah that's good I think Holly
Hunter is in it too if I'm not mistaken
right uh Danny Rowling just also said
the sequel Bud the chud 2 ripped off the
film's Return of the Living Dead Two
yeah that's what I was thinking and
flesh eater in some scenes
um and then Danny Rowling also said
night of the Comet we still need to do
United the comments too because I
actually really I really like that movie
too
that was on shutter not too long ago I
don't know if it's still on there
actually you know
the best horror franchise at one time I
would probably say this Friday the 13th
and probably at other times I would have
said it might have been Nightmare on Elm
Street or something but no recently I I
got off into them Phantasm and there's
five of them I think and all of them are
excellent and that movie has its own
Mythos and its own ethos and everything
um as far as B movie horror goes
I just got to get give it to Phantasm
it's got fantastic scripts really good
[ __ ] likable characters it's never
boring
um it's
the stories are told right and they're
just fun real fun
even the first one was a damn low budget
Masterpiece I remember it as a kid
we couldn't see it we were too young and
I could remember we're just seeing clips
of it it was scary as [ __ ] just uh the
the trailers and then
ended up seeing it on VHS later
that must have been around
1979 or 80 I think baby when I and it
scared the [ __ ] out of me in 1980.
[ __ ] Phantasm when I thought I was
watching [ __ ] snowflake
it was like I was watching something I
wasn't supposed to be watching I feel
guilty about watching it scared me but I
liked it and then they got better what
was funny is it had comedy in it and it
really couldn't the two at the time I
couldn't fit them together I was too
young I didn't understand horror uh that
well you know
it was weird man but uh overall that's
the best series that's the best
franchise right there well because all
of them are good they're all good
whereas you know yeah Nightmare on Elm
Street the first one's awesome the third
one's awesome but then some of them are
like yeah they're just okay you know
like I said Friday the 13th a good one
the first one's good second one's good
the other one's okay fifth or sixth
one's good and then the rest of them
were just kind of like apart kind of
like lame and then it starts to be
[ __ ] on itself you know what I mean
and [ __ ] Phantasm never shat on
itself and it's consistent you can tell
it's the creation of one man who's
trying to write this [ __ ] you know what
I mean and holding the story together
and he does a great job and that last
one was a Reaver I think was I think
it's called Reaver ravaging ravager
that's right I think it was four five it
ended up in a Mad Max type situation and
that's how it ended and I was just going
oh man so I can't wait if there's a I
hope this six is coming out I'd love to
see that when John gloris points out
Evil Dead yeah Evil Dead is awesome yeah
evil Dead's good too but because all
three of those were good and they had
the series and the series if you haven't
seen aspirations people did is amazing
yeah please see the series but when you
watch Evil Dead one and two it's almost
the same movie it's like yeah they
essentially are the same it's the same
movie they're all good though yeah yeah
I have to say that too Evil Dead you're
right the whole Evil Dead and and
[ __ ] and um Phantasm but I think
Phantasm actually might be better
they're both good but I think I think I
like Phantasm better than Evil Dead
it's still more
original they're just coming up with
ideas they're like what you know making
up their own things little Jawas on in
other dimensions and
stealing bodies and bringing bodies back
to life and
you know it just has its own take on I
think it's totally original
Pat says maybe the title chud kind of
programs you to expect a comedy I think
that's kind of what it was yeah because
it's almost like the title is so goofy
it's like it almost became a punch line
but I think that conversely like the
title being like that is I think what
maybe got it like the cult classic
status later on Danny Rowling also said
John heard's character in chud is pretty
much the same character from Midnight
Meat Train uh portrayed by Bradley
Cooper now the thing about that though
is that Midnight Meat Train is based on
a Clive Barker short story and I can't
remember what year that story came out
so that I did this story come out before
no it couldn't have like before this
movie because I know it was in one of
his one of the books of blood and I
can't remember when books of blood came
out I thought maybe mid 80s maybe late
80s I can't actually remember
and let's see
[Music]
I thought I saw something else that I
was gonna yeah somebody else said
copycat was great yeah I've been wanting
to re-watch that
Pat says first Phantasm was great second
one entertaining but if you look at each
movie except maybe the last one it's the
same story over again road trip though
yeah I didn't mind that though I didn't
mind yeah I didn't mind they were all
worthwhile they're just giving you
they're just giving you more what you
wanted reg comes back and he's bald and
he's still getting laid by women that
are [ __ ] half his age and then end up
being one-third his age towards the end
I mean they're making a big [ __ ] joke
about it you know it's just great you
know and you end up liking reg and you
you're following reg from the very
beginning all the way from Phantasm one
and how he he's kind of like ash from
Evil Dead you know he he
he's evolving in his Ki fight against uh
the extra dimensional Undead then the
mirror stuff and the [ __ ] tall man
and
yeah it's just
and that was named tall man yeah yeah
it's all man yeah
there's just it was just an it was just
a very
original take on it you know
but uh yeah once I was gonna say
something I totally forgot
what it was
oh I was gonna say uh if you guys have
shutter if you haven't noticed they have
they're putting up a new series which is
basically a 101 scariest movie moments
or something like that and each episode
is
50 minutes or something and they're
putting up one every week
um and they have three of them up now
and it's actually like a really good
show I've been like keeping up with that
so if you're interested in seeing like
you know has all your kind of regular
horror movie people like commenting on
different scary scenes in movies and all
that kind of stuff so it's pretty neat
oh uh speaking going back to talking
about chud Rob Zombie is talking about
remaking chud has been talking about
remaking chud thoughts how do we feel
about that
honestly maybe that might be okay like
there's some stuff that he should
probably keep his mitts off of like
Halloween yeah um well too late but um I
I wouldn't mind seeing him take a swing
at chud actually because he'd probably
make it a lot gorier and a lot like
funnier I like dessert I liked his
Devil's region yeah I like those I liked
his you know I liked his original films
I just said that usually like he's
always talking about like wanting to
remake certain films and some of them
I'm kind of like yeah I have at it but
like some of them
like stop it you know what I mean like
why would you want to remake Halloween
that's already good yeah you know I
wouldn't even mess with it I mean and
chud is a good movie too I like chud but
you know it's a great idea and they
maybe didn't have the budget and you
know maybe you could do something else
with it like with that you know uh
mythology so I don't know maybe I would
have like I said before I would like to
see him redo a Mega Man
it would be our last man on Earth or
Omega Omega Man reboot I think he I
think he understands it I think he'd be
I think he'd be great at redoing Omega
Man
yeah maybe although I feel like that's
been made so many times like that has
been adapted so many times yeah
well
that last one was okay it's a lot better
than I remembered it
but that's not quite
that's not quite the Omega Man story
and it's no it's it's also not quite I
Am Legend
and it's not quite last man on Earth
either it's just you know
I I think Rob Zombie could do an Omega
man that would be kind of like
an a better newer take on uh the one
that uh that had uh [ __ ] what's his
name in it with the talking mutants
that's the one it should have been
should have been like that with the with
the uh with the family and everything
what was the name of that guy
not Charlton Heston yeah yeah Charlton
Heston the Heston
[ __ ] chest and that's what you call
him also known also known as Moses
[ __ ] Moses shows up
but um yeah he's something else I do
they got away with a lot of [ __ ] back
then
they did get away with a lot of [ __ ]
back then
Danny Rowling said Eli Roth and
Tarantino could do chud Justice yeah I
could see that I could see that you
might even want to do it I kind of feel
like if you're gonna remake chud I think
it should be set in the 80s and it
should be set in 80s New York City
because I think that's like such a big
part of its charm and I think if you try
to like make it modern I don't think it
would be any fun
you know what I mean
I don't know like I kind of feel like
Rob Zombie has his own thing going on
um and I'm not sure if chud is really
the same
thing as his usual thing you know
I don't know
he seems like more of like
you know like with Devil's Rejects and
all that kind of stuff he seems more
like a Texas Chainsaw Massacre you know
what I mean deserty kind of I'm doing
this stuff like out in the desert with
tumbleweeds and serial killers and [ __ ]
like that like I said he's very Texas
Chainsaw Massacre oriented and I just
kind of feel like chudd is such a New
York story that maybe they should get
like a more
New York Film you're in there kind of
talking [ __ ] about Rob Zombie that you
know yeah
I think Rob Zombie needs to get away
from horror though
you know I'd like like I said I wanted
to see him do Omega Man I know he likes
that story he has songs about Omega Man
I like to see him do action Sci-Fi
Action
with some Horror in it that had been I
think he I think he could do it but you
know there's a lot of directors that
could probably do that but you know yeah
yeah Danny Rolex said stay the [ __ ] away
from a Rob creature of [ __ ] yeah
honestly like Rob Zombie stuff um his
original stuff I like his original
movies
um you know they're not my favorite but
you know they're they're pretty good for
for what they are but yeah the remakes
I'm not really and I'm I have no idea
how I feel about this whole monsters
thing
I have no idea I saw the trailer and I'm
just like I think it's a bad idea I'm
like do I hate that I'm not sure
it's gonna be a disaster I didn't know
like how I was gonna feel it's gonna be
a disaster it probably will it just
seems I'm not I'm not like saying that
Rob Zombie doesn't love the monsters I'm
sure he does but it's just kind of like
I don't I don't know how that's gonna
work out it's not okay I don't know how
it's gonna work now in this day and age
Danny Rowling said Tom savini should do
it what it should do chud oh okay I mean
Tom savini could get away with he's good
for doing anything
he's good for special effects and stuff
I I don't know he um he directed The
Night of the Living Dead remake from
1990 which is actually like a pretty
decent uh
his Knight of Living Dead stuff is kind
of hokey though you know he's got a he's
got a weird sense of humor
all right are we done yeah okay so
tomorrow is Monday and we're gonna be
talking about a haunting we have not
decided what
what no I'm tired uh we keeping you
awake sorry
[Laughter]
we haven't decided what uh uh episode
we're gonna do yet
because here's the thing like my
birthday is tomorrow and so I was like
oh it'd be cool if they had like a
haunting episode that had a birthday in
it and everybody said oh that one with
the soldier with the picture and Tom's
like yeah but I don't like that episode
so oh so we probably won't do that one
so we'll probably not about the birthday
angle if it's a birthday angle then I
guess we gotta do it no we don't got to
do it we can just pick another one it
doesn't matter I don't remember that I
don't remember that case being all that
interesting or compelling
we'll have to find something in a long
time we'll have to find something okay
you can go in there and pick whatever
one you want and then I'll post I can't
even pick them up because I don't
remember the names the names all sound
the same
yeah
have we done have we done the haunted
Victorian
episode
um I think that's season eight isn't it
no season seven
well we're gonna have to go dig around
then we'll see which ones we haven't we
haven't done yet
and uh yeah and then we can talk about
that so I'll announce it like tomorrow
like I'll put it in the YouTube
Community tab we never did the pilots
man I'm a [ __ ] Mr Gordy and all that
do they have those available to stream
yeah
we did do Mr Gordy we did a show about
it a long time ago there's two of them
and then I know I'm pretty sure I know I
know we did Connecticut
I'm pretty sure we did that one too did
we yeah I'm pretty sure I thought we did
like a whole episode okay based on both
of those I mean I wrote it down I know
for sure we did Mr Gordy because I
remember making the card that was a long
time yeah that was weird that's a good
case okay then we probably did that one
already yeah I don't want it it's not in
the set
yeah because like I said there are
cassette movies
A Haunting in Connecticut could have a
birthday cake
maybe we probably did that already I
think we did that one like I'd have to
go back and check that's a pretty big
case it is yeah that's what I'm saying
so I'm pretty sure we did like an
episode of that but I don't know I'll
figure it out um the monster in the
apartment
remember monster yeah we could do that
one we'll just I'll just go through them
and try we'll go through on it and find
it and I'll announce it like I'll put it
in the community Tab and I'll put it on
uh the Facebook page like the 13 o'clock
Facebook page like which one we're gonna
do so I'll give you like a few hours if
you want to like watch it before we do
the stream so you can like follow along
but uh but yeah so hopefully you guys
have a good rest of your weekend and we
will see you guys again talking about a
haunting tomorrow evening bye